I watched on the History Channel there's
actually the government keeps a list of
Preppers really yeah for emergencies
they figure out who they are there for
good thing good reasons not always
because if it came in 2012 I believe
Obama signed pretty much martial law
into order what yeah did you know this
you don't know this okay so in 2012
Obama signed martial law and order and
you can put that in you can google that
Obama martial law I can't remember which
executive order was with an executive
order and what that says is during an
emergency or a catastrophe was the
language during a catastrophe
essentially the Constitution is
suspended I'm talking about Bush though
no residential directive 51 no no I'm
not I'm talking about Obama did this in
2012 in an executive order so
essentially that puts its suspended
Constitution I mean people think oh this
is great this gonna be Anarchy but it
just means that the government could do
whatever it wants because the
Constitution limits the government it
doesn't give you rights yeah so so yeah
he send that in to order so once that
kind of happened they started making
lists and you know like camps late like
our places like FEMA most of what they
do is actually prepping most of what
they do right prepping for disasters you
know they have camps it's what they do
it's not all like aiding people for
floods it's mostly what they do is like
preparing for like the end of the world
is what FEMA does and a lot of people
don't know that but yeah the Obama
signed the executive order and I was
going somewhere with that and I
completely forget well you know what 51
is no this was George W Bush signed its
presidential directive 51 National
Security presidential directive 51 mm
allows the President to overthrow the
government in the event of certain
circumstances so Obama's was just like
more of that yeah that's why I don't
that's why I find that strange because
it's like well I need at least signed
them and then go about their way like in
essentially protests no no nothing like
that
and essentially if that happens there's
there's nothing that we can do and they
can come in and take whatever the
preppers have they can take all those
supplies and do whatever they want with
them well I mean anybody gun could if
everything
exactly if the Constitution suspended
then well no I mean if you know if the
apocalypse came oh yeah maybe
institutions gonna be piece paper yeah
God was not gonna care mm-hmm you ever
you know about the game fallout if you
ever played fallout or anything like
that I've never played it but I do know
that they did film part of it in my
hometown film yeah yeah they do this
like oh right right right right right
right right when they did fallout 4 it
was in Boston yeah yep and they did of
Western Mass - yeah yeah they got in
there and they did some filming well so
there's there's a faction called The
Enclave which is like remnants of the
old government and like the elites and
everything and that's what's gonna
happen if there's like a major
catastrophe the first that will happen
is the president will probably an actor
you know activate director 51
yeah which the which which allows the
creation of a single branch government
it's supposed to be a constitutional
government and its implementation is
supposed to be in the circumstance of
like mass loss of life or economic
catastrophe or something yeah so it's
the general idea is that the u.s.
government will persist in the event of
global chaos yeah but it opens the door
for unchecked absolute power because
theoretically if there's a massive loss
of life in China Trump could be like I'm
overthrowing the American government and
creating a new government if I want to
yep now I'm only saying Trump is
president now I don't want to play this
stupid game at the left plays were like
Trump's a dictator no any president
could do it yeah Obama could have done
at Bush could have done it and now who
comes after Trump could do it and so we
could we could I mean
I'm gonna say it it's possible Trump is
president for life yeah let's say
coronavirus really does reach 67 of the
60% of the global population with the 2%
marette mortality rate we're looking at
93 million dead and then Trump says you
know and seriously not because he they
want a keep something that's what but he
seriously says we're facing such a great
and massive threat with his massive loss
of life we have to suspend you know
elections we've got to shut down we got
to secure the borders and we got to go
overtime because there's an apocalyptic
event and they'll still be protests
about securing the borders yeah I know
that's the craziest thing to me like
right now we've got the corona virus
mm-hmm and we're trying to track it
mm-hmm our people still going to be
upset with CBP
Customs and Border Protection yeah no we
really do need them especially now
mm-hmm there's also the crazy thing too
it's like a lot of people coming in
aren't vaccinated
yeah so there's a lot of reasons why we
want to guard our borders mm-hmm we're
not in a magic world of you know candy
canes and rainbows and lovey dovey
whatever and I get it and I mean as a
min arcus personally I believe the
government's purpose is three things
it's military defense and then the
courts justice police that sort of thing
that's that's where I believe that we
would need that's where the founders
believed we would need a functioning
government it's just in those that facet
the very the very so little government
you can barely see it that's what Rand
Paul says what about regulations I mean
[Music]
there's there's places that I think that
is overkill and there's places that I'm
like okay you know I personally I'm okay
with that
like but like what happens when you get
too many and then you have a massive
government yeah I mean that's it's just
gotta be able to draw lines in
appropriate places cuz I was talking to
some Trump supporters and I can't member
exactly what was said but I said
something like uh if you can persuade
someone to hand over their money that
should be your right that's a free
market yeah and I said I disagree with
that because then you get fraud and you
get liars there's got to be some limits
and they were like if someone's stupid
and gives up their property that's their
fault not yours and I was like so you
realize the media operates on that
principle right and they lie about the
president all day and night to get those
ad clicks they'll call Donald Trump the
worst names in the book so that these
angry and outraged people will get angry
and angry and get their confirmation
bias when they click on yep
they wrap them up in this in this bias
bubble to manipulate them so that they
can make money so shouldn't that be
wrong and they're like well you know
it's actually even like right I don't
think they should it's tough because
instead of the media I can recognize
it's wrong but there's a First Amendment
right mm-hmm but then if you have like
you know a company that sells snake oil
mm-hmm yeah I don't think they should be
allowed to do that
because yeah people are dumb but it's I
think the issue is not so much whether
regulation is good or bad it's it's
where the line is on
too much and what should be regulated
ultimately it's not about you know
regulation bad it's kind of like well
some are some aren't and we just need to
keep working through the system to
figure out what is and what isn't you
know appropriate and the thing about
libertarianism it's not it's not Anarchy
it's not like pure unfettered anarchy
that's not libertarianism libertarianism
it's like okay where where could a
functional government be useful like I
mean for me personally when it comes to
courts injustice if we privatize the
courts can you imagine how dirty and I
mean they're already bad enough in some
places you know where it's bought out
wait a sec guys better now yes exactly
you know I'm like it so so a place like
that I'm like okay well it needs checks
and balances and if that's it the only
way to do that is to publicly is to
publicly um you know make it the
government then there you go I mean
unless there's some sort of well treads
forced transparency yeah it's it's it's
really tough because the way I see
government versus the private sector is
there's very little difference and
that's what a lot of I think a lot
people on the Left don't seem to
understand now why you I would have said
the right maybe ten years ago but I
think it's definitely changed with the
modern version of the right not so much
that switched but like I would it used
to be that I would say the left and the
right both misunderstand because the
right says government bad the left says
corporation bad and I'm like they're
just institutions yeah
however they're controlled are
implemented the power they have is the
power they wield it doesn't matter if
it's the government doing it or a
massive conglomerate doing it today I
look at Republicans and they're like
unchecked power from these massive tech
companies as a dangerous thing mm-hmm
and also the government yeah and I'm
like okay and then up to the left and
they're like government good tech
companies good monopolies good and I'm
like what is going on there's an
interesting I think it was brought up at
mines in real life this summer yeah and
a big tech bill of rights or in it right
right yes that's what it was and it
sounded you know like okay well because
everything they're in is terms and
service and it's completely subjective
it's at their whim it's like well this
is hate speech when you say it but it's
not hate speech when they say it you
know things like that and it's like what
nobody knows what's safe to say and
you're always on eggshells so it's like
alright we'll create a dinner
Bill of Rights you know and figure out
what is it's it's so obviously one-sided
it's so obvious that censorship and from
private private companies is one-sided
and for whatever reason because it
empowers them today it's the left saying
good yeah and so you get there was a you
know Zero Hedge yes they got they got
banned for publishing public information
about a researcher Wow but I did think
they said something like about showing
up at their door or some like that so
the point is I I you see it over and
over again yeah you know James O'Keefe
got banned for publishing publishing FEC
records like that's insane and he was
forced to delete any material that they
don't want you to see or no it's just
they're biased yeah Veritas is is is
wrong and bad so they're gonna suspend
him on Twitter yeah meanwhile the idea
laws on the other side get a free pass
yeah and then like what do you do if
ones like will create a new social media
sites like okay so you go to the new
social media site how long though until
that one you know might get bought up
because that's what well not brought up
but they're shutting them up shutting
them down that too you know and so you
think of like Facebook bought Instagram
you know like okay there's two huge
platforms right now owned by the same
person like it's it's not just that
though it's what makes a website work as
a huge chain yeah you've got like when
it came to I think gab maybe could be
wrong no no no this was I think the
daily stormer Google actually seized
their domain Google did like had no
right to do this and they're like too
bad I guess it's like the wild wild west
on the internet because there is no so
you're right you've got your hosting
service you've got domain name service
your registrar then you've got financial
services yeah and even Google is in the
way yep any one of these can be like
we've banned you and then also in your
website doesn't exist anymore exactly
yeah
so that's that's the terrifying future
that we're actually digging into and for
some reason you you you have this world
where was George W Bush who created you
know directive 51 yeah Obama who expands
upon it apparently yes
and now we're what is this strange world
where the Democratic Party became the
party
wealthy mm-hmm the Republican Party is
the populist movement the left is
championing massive corporations and
government it's because of their
confirmation bias I don't know this is
you know this is this is the big problem
I have with like with the big prom I
have with the Bernie Sanders people is
the massive government control yeah
socialism is good they say and it's like
why would you monopolize power within
any institution let alone with one with
a monopoly on violence yeah
not interested mm-hmm it's like how they
simultaneously call for gun control and
then they want you know they say Trump's
a fascist Trump you take all our guns
all of them all of them every single one
like in Virginia they wanted to ban even
like semi-automatic and send me
semi-automatic handguns mm-hmm and they
call them assault weapons by that's
insane thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we're live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. and if
you want to catch the full recorded
podcast which doesn't appear in these
clips make sure you join by clicking the
button down below become a member and
then go to the community tab of this
YouTube channel and you can see all of
our full episodes don't forget to like
share and subscribe if you wanna get
more clips like this thanks for hanging
out and we will see you all in the next
show
you